I've got sense as your little girl grows
up it seems like no guy will ever be
good enough for her I'm very excited for
you to meet my boyfriend but sooner or
later this is his house I'm sure this
isn't an apple store or something it's
time for you to meet the love of her
life
[ __ ] Fleming's are in the house
yes oh my god get up here please Pete
please
Emily baby [ __ ] yeah this is the first
serious boyfriend yeah I remember being
that age don't you just always ready
turns out her boyfriend is this internet
zillionaire Laird it's a really good guy
and his heart is always in the right
place he ate it he just literally has no
filter
I'm so [ __ ] psyched that you're out
here for the holidays the 15 year old
child [ __ ] you won't say father heck
yeah cuz you do what's your favorite
cuss word titties don't see titty
classic what else you got
[ __ ] double [ __ ] oh wait we're
holding double deke it's not like it's
today this kid is nasty and I [ __ ]
like it yeah head
Christmas Day it has Stephie to marry me
and I'd like your blessing
the answer's no why don't you give me a
few days Lina over by Christmas morning
you're gonna be calling me son
how many calling you dad don't think
that's gonna happen I think it's gonna
dad don't what dad stop it all right
dad yes siree Bob you could be dating
anyone why Laird he makes me really
happy I think it's going great I think
they've already accepted me
I'm getting a little bit a different
vibe that kid is wrapping his tentacles
around every member of this family
you've even got tattoo with his name oh
yeah that is so cute you are not the guy
we want our daughter married you want to
play with me you are going down you
really hurt my feelings
tonight bought your company game for
everybody calm down I think you might be
insane insanely in love with your
daughter
miss you okay we're Scottie my god he's
under that move Oh tea bagging you bro
quit a pen step you get him up here
please kiss please turn zout her
boyfriend is this internet zillionaire
I'm so [ __ ] psyched that you're out
here for the holidays the 15 year old
child